[Music]
that he used to ride his Harley around
is that what's happening which had no I
mean obviously
Hydraulics better than Brendan who just
rides Mark Harley around yeah that's a
really good point
that's why Mark Carly that's why Mark
Carly always has to have a handlebar
mustache oh I was I was thinking he'd
put Pigtails in like when he wears a
dress no no no those are like you know
how you know like on bicycles you just
put the little little tassels
on the side that's what his hairs are
yeah
he really does look like he really does
look like Falcor they really should just
call his podcast a never-ending story
yeah he never shuts the [ __ ]
put a little wicker basket on his
forehead
put a little blink blink he really does
look like a brand new wrestler that
you're like what is his gimmick
we need to get the [ __ ] falcore theme
so that every time more Carling pops up
on the screen you can play it oh you
know what they should do Mercy the Elias
thing you should shave and get a haircut
and then come back as his younger
brother bark Harley yes is his younger
brother Mike Harley Mike Harley yeah
so you inspired me my choice of
motorcycles I'm still a fan if vanessa
Harley was a bike he'd have white tires
if Mark Carly was a bike he'd be a Vespa
he came I came because Mark Harley was a
bike he'd have a baseball card in his
ass cheeks
Mark Harley was a bike he'd have no seat
that one was my fault I don't care thank
you so much [ __ ] Mark Harley and his
stupid ass
Clark Harley and his silly looking man
yeah I don't want to [ __ ] we by the
way Mark but can I okay now we'll just
move over to this because I wanted to
say this anyway
Mark Harley runs runs runs all of um
runs all of Gringo Poppy's uh socials
right where's all the Brandon socials
he got Brendan's thick boy whiskey or
whatever tiger thick whiskey or whatever
the [ __ ] he sells he's been running
is that guy his Instagram for it and he
got the Instagram taken down like the
entire thing yeah because he would yeah
yeah yeah because he was fighting Oh I
thought he said like he got popped I
didn't know it was no it's done it's
gone because he kept fighting with fans
that's awesome by the way
his whiskey brand not like Mark Carly
was fighting with fans with his account
um but that's wild yes he's so he's he's
in hot water you know what sucks with
Mark Harley in the doghouse as they say
what sucks with Mark Carly is this is
about everything Mark we control your
algorithm do you get that like nobody
else talks about you we're gonna steer
it wherever we want yeah nobody nobody
will go do this right now nobody talks
about you except us okay buddy
oh haters haters will say you're nothing
without us
haters will say that
haters will say you only get views
because of us
um who's that kid with progeria that
Mark's talking about I don't know
apparently this episode
apparently this whole app this is 56
minute episode talking about Tren about
steroids I swear to God that dude looks
like he was just evacuated from The
Matrix vat that's it
man I'm just happy Kyler found a new
co-host finally I was gonna say he
landed on us I was going to say this
this is this is Adonis Paul before he
gets cartoonified there you go oh my God
is before they dropped him in the
cartoon Bat yeah yeah there he is
um
like first of all I I think he's
his temperament and his generosity with
people that I've seen like he's a guy
is also very like quick to compliment
other people which I think is always
this like than most of us so whatever he
is doing yeah like he is a master of
like bodybuilding Zoo you know I'm sure
we'll meet up at once here's like what I
know but framing it is that it's like ma
what I know and what I you know can pass
on but you have an advanced
pharmacological understanding you know
not only from the theoretical
perspective wow he is really fake smart
like
I'll put it this way
he is playing a similar game that I play
just to to a ridiculous degree like he's
playing to his strength he has a good
vocabulary I'll give him that I have a
good vocabulary
I'm also a [ __ ] idiot you know what I
mean like you can use your good
vocabulary to either try to be funny or
try to sound smart when you do it to try
to sound smarter than you are you come
off like a pompous ass like so that's
his thing he has a good vocabulary he's
verbally probably smart like if you gave
Mark Carly a test
like an IQ 10 an IQ test but what do you
go like this SATs you probably score
really good on the verbal and then the
rest of it he would probably be like
borderline [ __ ] so it's like he's
not a smart guy he's not philosophically
smart or smart he doesn't have like a
like he doesn't have like a spiritual
depth to him or any kind of insightful
nature he just has a good vocabulary and
he's good at being like he's one of
those guys that you can tell just sits
there with a thesaurus yeah learns words
it could be like you have a great uh
theoretical pharmacological background
shut up just [ __ ] stop Mark Harley is
somebody who is he still hasn't picked
what he wants to be
you know what I mean like when you're a
kid you go I want to do this or I want
to do that or this is what my career
Mark Harley's somebody who like kind of
wants to be a bodybuilder but he also
kind of wants to be a comic but he also
kind of wants to be a podcaster but he
also kind of wants to be a philosopher
but he also kind of wants to be a
stand-up check of all trades master of
none yeah exactly and and it's it's a
matter the more things you do the more
poorly you do them at least master of
come but yeah I'm with you so he's the
kind of guy who kind of wants to be a
top but loves being a bottom power
bottom he can't help it because he likes
being a top bottom but he wants everyone
to think he's a top exactly
that you can't do anything big bottom
line yeah you know you look great you're
super strong in the gym you're a [ __ ]
animal but then as soon as you do
something else that's not bodybuilding
yeah you kind of immobile yeah so that's
why I kind of slim down and calm down
and that's why I do I think as you get
older your goals shift a little bit and
you're just trying to maintain what you
have
and and then you can do that on list
drugs and maybe more uh you know
longevity stuff like intermittent
fasting so here's a question I have
and obviously I want to be clear here I
don't I no I I
don't want anybody kicked off anything
but I just want to point something out
we got a strike okay we got a strike
on our on our channel the the YouTube
channel because Dayton hypernova was
talking about
the virus okay we didn't even say
anything remember that and we got hit
with a medical misinformation strike and
I was like what
Mark Carly every single show by the way
on Brendan's Network talks about the
correct way to use illegal steroids
what we did which was have Dayton
hypernova mentioned something
versus
basically telling people how to do
steroids not not only just telling
people how to do steroids how to obtain
them illegally yes suggesting illegal
means for obtaining said steroids yeah I
mean remember go on the dark web
bro look I'm just telling you because I
I know you're you know you're getting
like 2 000 views and that's adorable but
the thing is once more people start
watching your show because we're
bringing attention to it and they go to
mock you and stuff
you are going to get on the algorithm
and they're gonna notice you doing this
stuff and you're gonna start getting
strikes bro and I'm just telling you
this honestly
for your own good you probably shouldn't
do this kind of stuff at least not on
YouTube you know
less protein I just man the type of
human being that learns how to use the
Tor Browser and [ __ ] set up pgp keys and
[ __ ] like all for HRT that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] hilarious to me people do that
[ __ ] so they can buy pounds of heroin
and [ __ ] Mark Harley is buying
[ __ ] testosterone instead of buying
it from like a friend at the gym like
everybody else does you know what I mean
no honestly
the guy that's wearing jeans and a
[ __ ] and a leather jacket in a gym
he's got a brand new gym bag yes
those tags on it this is like why are
you wearing sunglasses dudes
hey why go to a doctor and collect blood
work just go on the dark web and just
put everything in your body all right
markers there's no reason why doctors do
blood work that's just [ __ ]
pharmacological [ __ ] uh back after
you right he says all that and then all
we say is hey maybe baby shouldn't get
the vaccine it's like get out of here
and we'll get out of here what was the
stupid analogy you're an S person I'm an
N person you know you go one way I go
the other so it's like yeah maybe you
[ __ ] go to a doctor and get blood
work done and you get like you know trt
based on a customized scale or you just
go on the dark web and you buy untrusted
hormones from untrusted sources and
inject them into your body let's go a
little bit better even Ronnie Coleman
who was Mr Olympia like seven times was
on was on Rogan like last year and even
Rogan asks them like you're on stairs
yeah of course I was on steroids he goes
but all the steroids I took were
literally prescribed to me by a doctor
right because even though the doctor is
Shady like you shouldn't have been this
this happened with WWE remember this WWE
got that's what the Vince McMahon
steroid trial was was they had a doctor
who was just prescribing steroids to
everybody so Ronnie Coleman had one of
those doctors but he's like but yeah man
I have my blood work done and every
month and stuff like to make sure and my
car is like just go on the dark ride but
shove it in your dick hole all right
yeah it's fine yeah it's fine yeah
yeah do you guys want to see Mark Harley
Act
we have seen him act like a woman I have
not seen him act like a man yet have you
seen him have you seen him act in a
short film from a channel that only has
30 subscribers 28 views this video only
has 600 views guys here we go
some fresh by the way I want to
apologize this is totally my fault I
don't care I started a mark Harley
tangent I don't care
meat is on there Harley cane baby meat
is on the menu boys
ah [ __ ] hi good morning
[Applause]
what
what regular hair
he looks like you [ __ ] douchebag
it's like you took every woman's [ __ ]
description of their date rapist ever
and made a composite
he looks like he remember remembering
the fir the Jack Nicholson Joker when he
put skin colored paint over his [ __ ]
wife oh my God guys
he does but with a man bun
this is like if Gozer said choose the
form of the destroyer and I didn't
picture anything in my head but I just
thought the word douchebag
and then a [ __ ] 200 foot Mark hardly
appears over Manhattan and you're like
well I know you hear that Mark you're
the dictionary definition of douchebag I
didn't even picture anything I swear to
God guys find a [ __ ] synonym for
douchebag and use thesaurus [ __ ]
idiot by the way guys can I point
something out we're four seconds into
this video this looks like a web how-to
uh of how to open the door for a
douchebag
you're not even going to have to think
too expect man I think an empty head
will fully make this guy [ __ ]
comments
I'm an embodiment of having no thought
I swear to God man it's like an
alternate universe John Cena where
instead of the being the modern day Hulk
Hogan he's just
well taper do me a favor can you bleep
that one out of it sorry buddy I don't
care make them work this this is like
this is John Cena this is John Cena's
character in train wreck
which you know Mark Harley probably lies
to people all the time and goes you know
I was up for that role yeah it came down
to me or seen it I mean obviously
they're gonna go let's see [ __ ] man I
know he's told that story before
must be Johnny I am indeed the one and
only
Sonia guess I'm in the right spot though
you are great come on in welcome
nice place thank you
okay okay
come on in thank you milady
I hate it I hate this is this what is
this
he literally did him a lady an
unironical lady
uh so how are you feeling today I'm
doing great actually I'm on vacation so
you're supposed to wait for the other
person to finish the line before you
start eating it's not great fine great
exactly I find that girl thank God
thank you for asking I really appreciate
it
but also this is the most unnatural
thing
it's the most unnatural dialogue ever
right okay so these people don't know
each other is this a date or something
like so he shows up and he's like he's
just like oh you must be Johnny or
whatever she's like you must be Sonia
and then he goes in and she's like how
are you feeling like what is it what is
it it's the phrase you just met
is she said doctor's appointment
well you know just looking to is this
the triage portion of their blind date
the only people they're gonna be triage
is awesome after this oh [ __ ] man I'm
gonna need triage after the sketch
because I'm gonna put my gun in my mouth
well [ __ ] good news they're probably
just gonna look at you in triage and
cinch you on down to the [ __ ] morgue
yeah
nothing we could do yeah great anything
that you'd like me to work on
specifically yeah the whole face your
attitude
we're gonna be in a better referee how
about that Aubry yeah it sucks it sucks
it sucks there's a guy and a girl in a
video and Mark Carly's the more feminine
of the two but doesn't she look like she
should be a refereeing a match and
taking all the [ __ ] putting taking
all the shine and putting it on her she
looks like she's like she should be
stealing the show during a [ __ ] aew
Main Event match she who does she look
she looks she looks like she lost a
cheek pinching contest
you Rosy cheek monster you've got cheeks
like my new cat oh my God she looks like
the [ __ ] that's gonna be screaming at
my kids in 12 years when they're playing
field hockey
she looks like she's about to take kids
on a Magic School Bus field trip
[Laughter]
she actually looks like the other mom at
that [ __ ] Fields field hockey thing
that you're that your wife would be
punching in the face
she hits my kid one more [ __ ] time
she looks like Lindsay Lohan if she
lived a normal life
oh my God yeah okay come on she looks
like she's uh the New York Governor
despite never being elected yes
seriously you'd like me to work on
specifically hmm you're out of town
but uh
everything
oh is this did that woman put on the
mask no
somebody stopped the sketch comedy video
he actually looks like Peter Green from
The Mask but before he puts on the mask
but it's a modern version he goes vaping
[Laughter]
full body
football please do not put a female mask
reboot out of the universe because I'll
[ __ ] get angry and it'll probably be
Melissa McCarthy got it yeah there we go
you know who I would cast from my female
mask I would just go [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
we're making a female mat Lena Dunham oh
there you go
okay
get her cheap
[Music]
you said that
all right guys we're missing this acting
come on
I found a 43 second video of Mark Harley
rapping when he was young oh we played
that one okay good yeah what needs the
most attention on my body how about why
is your double audio
that's totally cool missonia but just
for that cut yeah you saw that
um wait go back yeah I could tell you
why because they left in the sound from
both sources yeah because when he
transitioned from him talking and like
being on camera they transition to her
and that's the only time the echo's
there what I am going to let you be the
judge who needs the most attention on my
body how about that that's totally cool
Miss Sonia okay I mean yeah
um
so yes you uh any good at this massage
stuff
are you any good at this comedy stuff no
oh uh we need to go to San Francisco
clown college so he's [ __ ] pretty
good all right San Francisco Clan clown
college and tire adjustment I apologize
I I would say I am I've been doing it
I've had to expand they don't do German
cars though no confident I dig it
great I like that uh so Johnny I'm Gonna
Leave the Room I'll let you get
undressed during a live face down on the
table okay I'm gonna oh this is called
happy ending so I guess it's going to be
about him getting jerked off
that's going to be an extra 50. yeah
sound good perfect
I can't stop a white masseuse that gives
you a happy ending yeah that would never
happen that is sorry she has to be
aggressively Asian
I mean you can get away you want to give
you happy anyway enough for 50 Posh
Jesus Christ that's what I mean an Asian
will give it to you for 50 bucks thanks
a lot Joe Biden I mean you can find a
woman that'll give you a massage and a
happy ending that's why she's called a
prostitute not for 50 bucks
oh yeah not for fifty dollars that's
what we're talking about I mean actually
yes you can for fifty dollars it's not
one of those not gonna not gonna look
like that [ __ ]
okay so is this really gonna be a video
about him getting jerked off
yeah almost
so uh Johnny I'm just gonna get you to
close your eyes maybe he likes his video
because it reminds him of what he does
for Brendan every day
just a few short moments great
let me guess Switcheroo oh my God you
nailed it you nailed it I was gonna say
it there
did you know you're so special
ending is people like okay that you are
here we just want to make you feel good
so sit back and relax four times the
pleasure
I deserves a happy ending and he gets
mad that people call him big gay lion
yeah okay
have you tried it's reasonable not
acting gay all the time
it's pretty gay open wide
in any old weather
this okay this is a terrible skit
obviously but this should have been the
end right here right why is there still
45 more seconds of that's the joke was
this right there's nothing you could tag
on to this
oh my God no it's just him singing the
whole time
I told you he doesn't know what he wants
to be
no he well yeah you know he died I
disagree with you on one thing he knows
what he wants to be which is relevant oh
problem is he hasn't built any
particular set of skills to be relevant
like I I feel like he's pretty much
locked down what he wants to be he just
has no path to get there